We all have goals in life.
Some are short term.
Some are long term.
But what is the motivation out of which we
create and pursue these goals?
The reason we create goals in life is to create
and sustain a sense of motion.
Without feeling like we are moving towards
something, we feel useless and uninspired
and experience an existential lethargy.
We need goals to feel engaged and connected
to the natural world.
Every goal you set in life is ultimately a
goal of nature and evolution.
Even the most individualistic seeming of goals
are primed by some desire to benefit the collective
life around you.
You are a part of nature’s progression,
and if you wish to feel alive and a part of
the system of existence, you must move forward
with it.
Experiencing and participating in the collective
forward motion of life is essential, but we
must also be careful to not become so swept
away by it that we forget to also enjoy our
individual lives.
We must learn the balance between actively
working towards and pursuing our goals, while
still being able to enjoy our life around
them.
Our sense of identity and self-worth do not
have to be attached exclusively to the cycle
of goal-oriented success.
The cycle being; goal-task-accomplishment-repeat.
This cycle infinitely regresses on itself,
and searching for our overall wellbeing within
it will only leave us empty handed.
True wellbeing comes from enjoying and being
motivated towards goals, while not solely
depending on them for a sense of enjoyment
and self-worth.
When your goals become your only lifeline
to life itself, you bring anxiety, desperation,
risk-aversion, and fear into them.
It is important to be motivated and passionate
about the outcome of your goals, but the paradox
is not being so overly dependent on them that
you forget to enjoy them and take risks to
develop them.